[Music]
these days esports's biggest stars
routinely dismantle
old stereotypes about gamer health how
by getting swole
whether you look like you should be on
jersey shore the villain in a rocky
sequel
or the star of the next raid movie in
spite of how
sedentary esports is it's still a sport
fitness matters and the importance of
mental and physical health cannot be
overstated
then you will take the stress out of
these muscles up here which
will go up in your neck and this will
have a
positive influence on the training and
the long matches when you're sitting in
front of the
computer from pub stompers to push-up
fiends to
full-blown papitos competitive gaming is
in no shortage of
muscular mouse clickers who've proven
that if your goal is to blossom into a
world-class e-gamer
you're going to have to sweat both in
and outside of the server
what do you want you want to get one top
one one tap
one tap okay let's go come on
let's go
but i think it's fair to say that all of
them pale in comparison to denmark's
newest counter strike commandant
literally how much how many kilograms
can you bench my one rip max
for a long time ago was 190 kilograms
meet the ever titanic
benjamin blame f van grammer complexity
gaming's
gargantuan igl who was just as capable
of
popping your head on the server as he is
off of it
it falls on to blame f in yet another
clutch flashbang goes out he cannot run
through this
and he's no it's obviously
on top
what a robbery a gentle but ingenious
giant who answered the call to wake
north america's
sleeping counter-strike colossus and
transform it
into a self-proclaimed juggernaut
and i'm coming then i'm dropping that he
was saying he was here
so why is it that this mountainous man
was trusted with redeeming the lost
legacy of a once
fabled organization how did he do just
that
and is it possible that his brain is
actually more massive than the rest of
him
okay so if you are unfamiliar with the
impossibly
boisterous blame f there are essentially
two things you need to know
first he's a certifiable brainiac and
second at the risk of sounding like i'm
stereotyping
he really doesn't look like it and look
i know plenty of professional players
boast brains as big as their biceps
but blame f this dude's on a whole other
level
this dude's torso is wider than overpass
it's like
nature adjusted his aspect ratio and
made it so that this literal
mack truck of a human was living in
fourth restretched
he is what evolutionary biologists refer
to
as an absolute unit you can see ben's
big shoulder on wells picture i think
massive shoulder who would win an arm
wrestling match
between you and rush i would destroy him
[Music]
anyway i'll stop fussing about his
physique since it wasn't just his bench
presses that caught the community's
attention
it was his hustle it wasn't just
treating him it was like a lifestyle i'd
like
i think it taught me a lot about my
discipline and hard work because
no one saw me when i went to the gym
like one hour before school just to
encourage you and then i went to school
and then i went
to the gym again and then i went to my
job and then i went home and went and
did homework
so no one like no one sees what you're
doing when you're doing like
bodybuilding
you're just doing it for yourself and no
one really recognizes how much hard work
that goes into it
you see blame grinded just as hard in
the server as he did in the gym
this dude legitimately woke up one day
thought to himself i want to become a
world-class counter-strike competitor
and then did is it true that you
practice ten thousand head shots for
three hours every day
i don't do it anymore but i definitely
did it for like a period of eight months
without the
out-cursing i streamed it most of the
time as well if you aim for like
something that's so good in the aimbots
then like if you achieve just half of it
in official matches then you're going to
be a better player but
this is how i aim in officials but what
separates blame from every other cracked
up and comer is that he didn't
just dm spam retakes and hang out in
aimbots all day no as he said on hltv
confirmed
he watched vods reviewed demos and
generally became obsessed with studying
the game from a strategic standpoint
i think i just fell in love with like
the technical aspect of counter-strike
and the team aspect of counter-strike
and the more demos i watched the more
interesting that became rather than just
sitting and playing fp and all that
now part of the reason he did this was
because he just genuinely
loved the game but the other reason is
that
he sort of had to i was kind of in a
point in my career where no ideas wanted
to pick me up i remember i like wrote to
some of the different ideals in the
daimy scene and asked him
if they could give me a shot and some of
them ignored me and some of them just
said like no
i'm not really interested but no one
really wanted to play with me
so i kind of had to become an ideal in
order for my team to succeed now like a
lot of scrappy danish self-starters who
love
counter-strike almost as much as they
love screaming
blame f bounced around a handful of
lesser-known
rosters before finally getting his first
big break
on heroic and it was with that roster
that he
really started to blossom not only as a
player
but a leader the point in my career or
like the point in any teams when i found
out that
i i should be an ideal is honestly when
i heard other ideals talk and i'll add
it
and i could just hear that they're not
doing a good job i know something we had
like a problem and they wouldn't have a
solution to it and i would be interested
like
well it's like we just have to think
logically and then the solution will
come like
and now into blame if now in a one
versus two with 24 seconds
and he could actually block off a little
bit of a one side there
does pick up the bomb and back down on
the low ground oh the grenade that's
gonna be huge isn't it takes care of
saint harrison
gobby now left i think he's
snuck through the smoke oh he fires the
gun right in top that means at least
blame if knows where he's the grenade
does absolutely nothing a copy does not
have armor so this fight is hugely
favoring flame if but he's gonna win it
too
and blame is alone he's in the middle of
the bomb side just has to take the fight
and what a fight it is
blame shutting it all down that is so
unlikely picks up a quad kill now he's
got the pissed out and he's gonna ace
and that's the third ace into a single
half that we're seeing here in this game
but that wasn't where he
really started to make a name for
himself you see blame
genuinely wanted to be the best people
say that a lot
but with him it was different he
actually had the
insane super human work ethic to back it
up
i know i cannot be burned out like i
used most of my holidays sitting and
watching demos or
watching everything so when complexity
bombed out of the berlin major in august
of 2019
and jason lake put out his now infamous
juggernaut tweet
blame was the guy he turned to ebay just
reached out and
i talked to my family about and all that
and everyone just said like this is like
a big opportunity for you and
like you kind of like get to live your
dream now you need to understand
at first nobody took this roster
seriously
a very new team a very young team a lot
of names here that maybe you've never
seen before right
despite being actual juggernauts in 1.6
and source complexity struggled to find
the same level of consistency in go
after finishing top 4 at the first ever
major back in 2013
they failed to make top 8 again for 5
years needless to say complexity felt as
if they had a legacy
to uphold and blame with that trusty old
danish
grit was just the man to do it he's been
playing really good recently and just
even talking to him i can see how
motivated he is to
make us a top team i haven't really
experienced like a real igl a lot
most i also had a kind of people who
like kind of just got were passed to it
you know
he seems like he really likes embracing
the role and he seems like it was really
natural to him
okay so how exactly did blame intend to
turn a meme
into a dream team well by following in
the footsteps of his compatriot
hero and the greatest all-around igl
that cs go has ever seen
glaive if you could spend a day with
anyone in the world who would it be
probably astralis what would you do with
them
i would want to like sit in a prague a
whole day and just like
hopefully learn a thing or two or
something you see like most of us
blame was a pretty big fanboy of
astralis arnold
sounding execute administrator the
difference is that he didn't just want
to
be that beautiful big brained son of a
[ __ ]
he wanted to beat him of course at that
time
nobody thought he could at least not yet
complexity were still
a very new team and despite putting up
some promising results in their first
few months
overcoming csgo's greatest ever team in
the so-called
group of death at blast premier spring
was a big ask
the question is can they play with the
big boys can they play the best in the
world and well they get the toughest
task right here
this is astralis this is this is not
comparable by any means but blame
had no intentions of being starstruck
this was his chance to
stick it to his heroes his moment
although
in the beginning it didn't look that way
the device is ready taking down poison
they just know everything this is the
what complexion they're doing it could
be fine but the fact that they're
getting caught and red all the way
through is a big problem over getting a
huge kill there on magus
but he's still gonna get shut down magus
gets blind and there's a chance
zipnic falls in mid but a double three
kills for the pre
and a fourth on top after we went behind
5-0
i think it was i was kind of doubting
because i could tell that people
were really nervous and we didn't play
like how we were supposed to play but
when we started like grinding rounds
back
i would tell i could just tell how easy
it was and everything i called basically
just worked
and we had a lot of people stepping up
individually i know bowen and one versus
two that's almost unwinnable he's gonna
stand up for a kill
oh my god he turns around for it an
unbelievable round the quad kill
poisons up next mega standing his crown
he's gonna lose the fight
zip still here still blind and still
shooting headshots yeah he's still in
there poison trying to push through but
if stays alive oh the flick comes in and
poison will take him down
how do you get through here he has a
molotov and a couple of flashbangs but
they have another molotov on blame
they could buy a lot of time it's a
triple kill instead actually a quad kill
he's blind and return and rush is gonna
try and hold the line
there's flames everywhere he's got a
triple kill
poison is gonna close things out it's
glaive again and a one versus four
map one is gonna go to complexity what a
way to win that was down to the last
second if rush goes down in the middle
of that they don't even get close i
think astralis just take long and win
the entire fight but instead he stayed
alive and there it is 16 to 11.
complexity do what nobody would have
expected and they take map one against
australis
after thwarting his fellow danes on dust
2
blame had a trick up his sleeve that no
one knew about
one that he'd been preparing since day
one
to obliterate the goat complexity
doesn't even have an official map logged
on vertigo
this i don't want to be that guy this is
where that life raft sinks i think
this is where it's like this is the map
where if you need to go get a drink if
you need to go like cook some food
this might be the one we definitely made
like a long-term game plan against solas
like
a decision that was made like a long
time ago and yeah we basically just
decided that we're going to practice
vertigo but we're not really going to
show it to anyone
and sure enough blame's sneaky beaky
plan
played out perfectly if complexity could
turn this around into a win that would
be huge
i can't believe it's even gotten this
close it was a five on three and they
had the bomb site and it's now
a chance for glaive low hp and oboe has
given up the position important
critical trade for blame f 25 seconds
and yeah they're gonna go oh
the molotov that's just almost a random
throw and they pick it up and now device
he's no one over they take him down over
again
another triple and another clutch for
him what a way to begin
they have to try and jump over the wall
and that's not gonna happen
poison goes down astralis they could
have probably done this if the bomb was
on the other side but they get
absolutely crushed
poison with two kills and then the bomb
on the other side of the wall
that is very strange this is absolutely
stunning
complexity two on two they have a slight
health advantage but
against these weapons for astralis it
might not matter
oh meg he had the hell for it but now
he's been taken out and sip
just trying to buy time flank it around
blame it hunting him down
he turns forward immediate defuse he's
right there with the kid
oh my god i can't believe it's 16 and
12.
complexity taking down astralis oh
what a way to kick off
your performance on land complexity the
very first game
they drew the best team in the world and
they've shocked them coming out of the
break
since that fateful day when complexity
two owed astral is
on land blame has gone on to become one
of
the most explosively successful igls in
cs go
blame which also is looking like a
really good in-game leader for me
blame uh is is stealing a lot of my
stuff so i need to steal it
as well he snagged a staggering sixth on
2020's hltv
top 20 and the consensus is that he's an
almost
unreasonably complete player he frags
plans and inspires all at an absurd pace
and as far as anyone can tell has no
intention of slowing down
i think play myth as an in-game leader
is incredibly hard working
i think he you've shown that with
hard-working with passion
you can come a long way he's always
prepared he's always trying to uh
to be better than everyone else right
he's trying to outwork other people and
and you put that kind of pressure on
yourself you also have to deliver
um i think he has the talent to do that
i think he has the work ethic to keep it
sustainable
he's working a lot he's working hard and
as an individual player you can see him
progress
all the time it's a dangerous shot to
miss again especially against such a
dangerous man but it doesn't matter
gets that kill eventually at least
notices that playmat is coming even
in from behind even if he doesn't get
the kill but suddenly it's a one-on-two
there is some hope now there's a smoke
that could be used to isolate the fight
but he expects the elevated crims
takes him down knows that brolin is in
towards the pit now puts the smoke in
where he's standing to make things a lot
more difficult
and just restrict that vision completely
brolin on the bicycle right now but he's
not cycling he's waiting for his feet
and there it is blame f would have won
on four to save the day for complexity
he keeps them in it
and despite running into a few hiccups
over the course of the so-called
online era such as losing his star
fragger to burnout
it's safe to say that blame f has done
exactly what jason lake hired him to do
put one of north america's most storied
counter-strike orgs back on the map
it's looking real good for complexity
maybe close this out
oboe continuing the defense downstairs
and it's all on the suture he's going to
get dropped at 16 to 12.
complexity are your champions ladies and
gentlemen amazing run here
at the blast premier spring finals and
it'll be
it'll be complexity in the understand
told but not only has blame revived and
revitalized complexity he's
revved them up for the first time in a
long time
the cowboys of counter-strike are a
force to be reckoned with
and it's all because of this jacked
jubilant
genius and his willingness to put in the
work
because for a guy like blame f the best
is simply never too much trouble
i'm actually not bad with accents oh
crispy hey mate but did you know that
england has
it's has so far and above the most
dialects of a single language
of any country any nation in the world
it's not it's not even close there are
something like an estimated
67 different dialects of english
[ __ ] crazy lot